well do not be alarmed folks I did as
you can see transition to the the summer
beard so I took quite a bit off and you
know whenever you would have a beard and
you make a beard change people always
feel entitled to give their opinions and
to tell you that they liked it better
before or whatever well let me just say
I have beard autonomy okay my beard my
choice and you can't make decisions with
my beard and I believe that strongly
although there are times when you know
someone likes the the change of beard
and that's offensive to so like you know
I I cut this down this morning that I
came out of the bathroom to show my wife
and I said hey it's a lot shorter what
do you think kind of shocking right and
she said no I think it's great I like it
a lot it's good and I said oh so you you
didn't like the beard before is what
you're saying you you thought I was ugly
before is what you mean you hated my
beard before just like you hate me and
then I ran back into the bathroom and
wept into a pile of beard clippings kind
of a weird way to start the day but you
know I try I start every day by weeping
in the bathroom actually
all right let's a lot of interesting
topics to talk about today but before we
do that I want to tell you about
dynatrap indoor fly light it's you know
it's summertime and the only thing more
annoying than people judging your beard
is when you have insects in the home
flies and that sort of thing invading
your home and who knows where those
flies were last you see them sitting on
your sandwich or your hamburger who
knows they could have been feasting on a
dirty diaper right before that so think
about that next time you see a fly we
would like to thank our sponsors then
over a dynatrap dynatrap is the leading
manufacturer of outdoor mosquito and
insect traps and now they've come up
with a solution for indoor pests as well
the dynatrap fly light the dynatrap fly
light works day and night to attract and
trap flies fruit flies mosquitoes other
pesky insects and I've got to tell you
something it really really works I can
tell you from experience I've got one
plugged in right over there you can't
see it
I've got we've got two plugged in all
around the house and we don't have any
bug problems it's a lot better than the
fly the sticky fly paper strips that you
hang and then the Flies get stuck on it
and it's dangling there and then you
walk into it gets wrapped around
your mouth and there's flies going into
your mouth you suffocate and die that
kind of thing happens every day in
America avoid those tragedies with
dynatrap fly light looks like a subtle
little nightlight that you plug in and
it works wonders and if you want to get
yours now which you do go to dynatrap
comm Dyn ATR AP comm into the promo code
walsh and receive 15% off any of their
products dynatrap the silent simple safe
solution to household insect control
alright let's begin with a story that
you would never expect to see in the new
york times but indeed it was in the new
york times the headline is this is what
it said it turns out that the happiest
of all wives in America are religious
conservatives you know that the New York
Times is readership they're gonna be a
big fan of stories like that and we'll
get to how the readership reacted in a
minute but the article begins Blu
marriages are better or at least that's
the conventional wisdom couples who live
according to a gala terian values
sharing domestic responsibilities like
housework and cooking have long been
seen as superior by most academics
journalists and public intellectuals
engaged in the national conversation
about the American family well there's
your problem right there first of all
that we've got intellectuals public
intellectuals journalists and academics
who are apparently leading the
conversation about the American family
well I don't really trust what any of
them have to say on the subject of what
makes the healthiest family I don't I
don't trust them on a lot of things but
especially on that subject so it's no
surprise that they were wrong the whole
problem with this equal marriage idea
the egalitarian marriage is that it the
problem is not let's be clear what the
problem is it the problem isn't that
spouses are sharing household duties of
course spouses should hair share
household duties I cook I clean I do all
that stuff I'm not a baby I'm gonna
contribute to the house clearly
everybody in the house should be
contributing kids too right
husband wife kids so that's that's great
but the egalitarian approach is
generally the way it works is it ends up
being a 50/50 thing kind of a splitting
Solomons baby
situation where I'll do 50 you do 50 if
I ever have to do 52 and you're doing 48
that is a travesty and an injustice and
so then there's always this
bean-counting going on that we has to be
exactly equal all the time where I go
this far you go that far neither of us
have to go further than the other person
goes and that yet that approach doesn't
work and it doesn't work because it's
selfish and and therefore it's not
sacrificial and in a marriage the thing
that makes a marriage tick and work and
the thing that's gonna make a happy
marriage is when you have sacrificial
service when you are sacrificially
serving your spouse which means that
you're not always keeping track to make
sure that they're doing equal to you and
there are going to be times when you do
52% and they do 48 there gonna be times
when you do 80% and they do 20% they're
gonna be aspects of running the family
in the house where you're doing almost
everything and your spouse's is doing
almost nothing in that area and then
there gonna be other areas where your
spouse is doing almost everything and
you're doing almost almost nothing it's
not equal so you're not you're not
focused on equality or just focused on
serving the house serving the family and
doing what needs to be done I think
that's the only way to have a healthy
marriage like in my family you know or a
single income family so I earn the
income and as far as earning income goes
I do basically 100 percent of that but
my wife what I'm gone she's doing
basically 100 percent of the parenting
of for that period of time so it's and
but we also can't say it's I can't
really say actually that I'm earning
100% of the income because I couldn't do
this if my wife wasn't doing what she's
doing and she couldn't do what she's
doing if I'm not doing this and so I
think that's the way that it works the
other problem with the equal marriage
thing and I'll get back to the article
in a second because I it'll take forever
to get through this if I pontificate for
30 minutes about each sentence that I
read one other thing though the the
problem with the equal marriage
fundamentally is that marriages are not
equal and cannot be equal because
husbands and wives are not
and they're not equal because they're
different I'm not saying that one is
superior to the other it's not the point
um
non equality is not always about
inferiority and superiority sometimes it
just means that two things aren't the
same equal means the same non equal
therefore means not the same if you were
to ask me our trees and flowers equal I
would say well that's a really stupid
weird non sequitur question no they're
not equal and then if you said what
you're saying trees are better than
flowers no what does that even mean
better I don't know what does that mean
no they're just different I like them
both they're both great I like having
them both in my in my yard they both
serve a purpose it's just they're not
the same as all and it's the same with
husbands and wives they're not the same
so they're they're not equal but it
doesn't mean that one is better than the
other all right going back to the
article it turns out the happiest of all
wives in America are religious
conservatives followed by their
religious conserve calendar parts fully
73 percent of wives who hold
conservative gender values and attend
religious services regularly with their
husbands have high quality marriages
when it comes to relationship quality
there is aj curve in women's marital
happiness with women on the left and
right enjoying higher quality marriages
than those in the middle but especially
wives on the right when we look just at
women's political ideology using the
general social survey another nationally
representative survey of American adults
we see a similar curve in marital
happiness for American wives it turns
out the bluest and reddest wives are
most likely to report that they are very
happy in their marriages to be sure the
general social survey curve is closer to
AU curve as the level of marital
happiness for the group of extreme
liberals and liberals and the group of
extreme conservatives and conservatives
is essentially the same together these
two groups account for about one third
of American wives all right the point is
what they're saying is that the people
on the so-called extreme ends of the
spectrum are the happiness happiest
while people in the middle are less
happy which may
so you got religious conservatives who
are the happiest and then second place
are progressive religious women and then
the people in the middle are miserable
it turns out now the article suggests
some reasons for that it says maybe
folks in the middle don't have the same
community support because when you're
affiliated with a group you know
religious group a church you're gonna
have that community support will make
you happier there's probably some truth
to that they also talked about how the
men on both ends of the spectrum tend to
be more involved which makes the wives
happier which obviously is true and I
think all that's true we'll get back to
them to the men in a second but I think
there's something else at play here and
it's much more foundational marriages
are happier and healthier when they are
structured around something around
something greater than the marriage
itself so the marriage has to have a
point to it that goes beyond itself and
it's the same for people we have to have
a point that goes beyond ourselves that
looks that looks outside of ourselves
above ourselves religious couples answer
to a to a higher authority they have a
higher purpose that they look to and
that they call upon so they're not
winging it as they go they're not making
it up as they go along they're not
confused as much and it means that
ideally that there's going to be
humility as well because both partners
realize that they are not the ones in
charge right I think non-religious
couples aren't always sure about the
grand plan ultimately they don't know
what direction they're going as a family
they make up their purpose every day
they try to build a new foundation for
their family every day and from scratch
and it just doesn't work there's going
to be confusion and resentment and
competition and all of that it all
creeps in when you don't have that
religious foundation
now the part about men is important too
the article says in fact in listening to
the happiest secular progressive lives
and their religiously conservative
counterparts we noticed something they
shared common devoted family men both
feminism and faith give family man a
clear code they're supposed to play a
big role in their kids lives and it
shows both culturally culturally
progressive and religiously conservative
fathers report high levels of paternal
engagement now I have to be skeptical
about the idea that feminism gives men a
code I mean the code for men and
feminism is shut up and get out of the
way which is exactly the opposite of
what you want husbands and fathers to be
doing but it is true that men do need a
code that's John Wayne said a man's got
to have a code something to live by and
he's exactly right about that religious
men have that code to live by which
gives them purpose and meaning and they
bring that purpose and meaning into the
family and it gives their family purpose
and meaning and I think that's where a
lot of the happiness comes from I
thought it was interesting reading the
comments about this article on social
media because the comments are filled
with people insisting that there's no
way religious people are actually this
happy let me read a few of these
comments it says this is hilarious they
all asked their spouses if it was okay
to answer the survey in the first place
then they made it a dinner table
conversation to make sure they answered
the questions correctly
I know evangelicals women do not have
separate lives this is this person sound
like someone who knows evangelicals yeah
they're all sitting around the woman the
wife was afraid to answer the survey so
they all sat around the table and the
wife said gee huh she should what should
we say folks should we all say that
we're that we're happy is that we should
tell the survey person and the husband
is sitting solemnly at the head of the
table you will say you're happy we are a
happy family damn it
that is that's how progressive secular
progressives see religious people that's
that's how they imagine our families
work it's not by the way someone else
says can confirm what all other x-men
Jellico's are saying self reporting on
this is not a reflection of reality
conservative women are
that being anything other than happy is
a spiritual and moral failure I have
never heard that taught ever in a church
someone else says what Christian wife is
gonna fill out a form with anything but
extremely happy it's in the Bible to
state things that might not be true to
bring them into fruition and on and on
and on what you notice about unhappy
people and I can call these people
unhappy because it's very clear uh that
I know that they're unhappy because
unhappy people cannot accept and don't
want to hear that anyone else is happy
if others people's if other people's
happiness makes you cynical and and and
ticks you off that's a pretty good
indication that you are a very unhappy
person and that's what you see happening
here
all right um let's let's move on so the
Republicans have decided to do a little
bit of nany stating they just can't help
themselves you know Republicans they
have a few good weeks and they got to
follow it up by going back to the nanny
state well and but this actually proves
this particular bill I'm gonna talk
about proves my theory that
bipartisanship is actually bad because
this is a bipartisan bill brought by
McConnell and Tim Kaine a Democrat and
this bill would raise the minimum age
for buying tobacco to 21 from 18 and the
idea here we're told is to stop the
epidemic of teenage vaping because
there's always got to be an epidemic of
teenagers consuming something that
they're not supposed to consume and
that's going to kill them and so we got
to have laws and pass laws and
everything to stop teenagers from doing
it and it never works ever never works
so let's get into this a little bit
raising the tobacco age to 21 okay so
first of all at 18 you are a legal adult
okay your parents are no longer
responsible for you they can kick you
out of the house and kick you to the
curb and it's not child endangerment
anymore
because you're not a child you can go
overseas and die in combat you can be
you can be executed you can earn a life
sentence you can vote you are an adult
and treated like an adult by the law in
every way except you can't buy a beer
and now they want to say you can't buy
tobacco products either and that's
absurd
it's simply absurd if a person is old
enough to fight and die for their
country they are old enough to buy a
beer period I think it's I think that's
a pretty straightforward and logical
equation if you are psychologically
competent enough to take on that
responsibility of fighting for your
country or to be held responsible for
committing a crime to the point of death
or to vote and participate in our
democracy if you're psychologically
competent for all of that then you're
psychologically competent to drink and
certainly to buy a tobacco product I
have never heard a good argument
explaining why a person should be able
to die for their country at 18 but not
buy a beer I have never heard a good
argument for that because every argument
always goes back to well I personally
don't like it I
that's that's every argument basically
is I don't like drinking it's better if
you don't in my opinion and so therefore
yeah eighteen-year-old shouldn't be able
to do it well there are a lot of things
that I that you might not personally
like and that you might not think
personally people should do but it
doesn't mean that we can set arbitrary
age limits and prohibitions and it
certainly doesn't mean that we should do
that or that those efforts by the
government are going to be at all
effective you know so
raising the age it accomplishes nothing
what has the thing about the drinking
age at 21 what has that accomplished has
it prevented a single teenager from
drinking I hate to scandalize with this
information but college kids are binge
drinking every night in this country
eighteen year old college kids are
drinking as much as they could possibly
want and way more than they should want
every single night and the laws against
it have accomplished nothing at all
sixteen year olds are playing beer pong
in their friends basements this is a
common occurrence the law is not
stopping it because alcohol is
everywhere because it's legal for
everyone else which means that there's
no that there is no shortage of it
and even if you did make it illegal for
everyone else there still wouldn't be a
shortage of it as prohibition
conclusively showed us so what does a
higher age limit for this kind of stuff
do if it doesn't actually accomplish
what it's supposed to accomplish well I
think it does two things number one when
you make the when you heighten the age
limit for something you make it seem
cooler to teenagers now this is one of
the basic truths of life and of
teenagers when you tell them they can't
do something it's just gonna seem cooler
to them which doesn't always mean that
you should tell them they can do it but
it is something to keep in mind that
whatever you're telling them not to do
if you've just made it cooler something
to remember it's a fact if you know any
teenagers or if you were a teenager
yourself at one point your life and most
people were I'm told then you must know
this drinking beer seems really cool
when you're 16 and 17 years old largely
because you can't do it legally now when
you get older in your of drinking age
you know I'm 32 years old I drink beer I
enjoy beer I don't see it as this cool
impressive thing with a mystique to it
where whenever I drink I gotta brag
about it
take pictures of myself drinking post it
online tell every hey man guess what I
had last night
a beer yeah pretty cool I had three
you know that whole thing grown adults
don't do that
that's a kids do that because they think
it's so cool because it's illegal is the
point and so not only have we made it
this forbidden elixir which is now cool
to kids but because they can't do it
legally in full view of everybody else
what we've ensured is that they're gonna
go down in their friends basement to
drink because every teenager has a
friend whose parents are neglectful and
don't pay attention to what they do in
the basement so they're gonna go to that
kids basement they're gonna drink
they're gonna go to house parties
they're gonna drink in a parking lot
somewhere at 10 o'clock at night I mean
they're gonna find a place to do it and
they're gonna do it and and so all
you've done is you you have ensured that
they aren't going to learn responsible
drinking from adults because adults are
now legally prevented from teaching them
responsible drinking so instead of
learning it instead of looking up to
adults and saying oh that's how you
drink responsibly they're gonna look
parallel to their friends and they're
gonna learn drinking habits from their
other irresponsible stupid friends
that's the way it goes and then as I
said once you hit the drinking age
alcohol loses the mystique and pretty
quickly in most cases people stop doing
keg stands and they just have a drink of
wine with dinner because it's a normal
everyday thing it's not a big deal
that's the point we make a big deal out
of alcohol in this country we make a
huge deal out of it and that only makes
it worse
whereas I think you'll find in some
countries where they don't make a big
deal out of it and where kids are you
know drinking wine with dinner at the
age of 13 again not every case but in
many cases you're not gonna have all
this binge drinking because it's normal
to them so
what the drinking age does makes alcohol
seem cooler ensures that kids are not
going to learn responsible drinking and
I think a similar thing will happen with
tobacco do you realize how cool
you'll make vaping seem to eighteen year
olds if you tell them they can't do it
they already think it's cool I don't you
know I personally if you're gonna have
to back all I think of cigars the way to
go but I guess I'm not gonna be doing
any anti tobacco PSAs anytime soon with
that message hey kids try to back try a
cigars instead you know no but it's it's
it already kids already like it so if
now you go and say oh you're not allowed
to do that - you're 21 it's illegal now
you'll get a citation if we catch you
vaping all you've done is you've
ratcheted up the vaping cool points by
like 50 it's completely stupid alright
um before we get to emails
Sally Goldenberg is a reporter City Hall
bureau chief at Politico New York she's
been traveling through Iowa apparently
venturing outside the safe confines of
the concrete jungle and she's been
shocked by what she's encountered and
she wrote this over the weekend she said
observations from Iowa it is very flat
driving is monotonous there is more
unbuilt land in one block that york has
in an entire borough dirt roads are
terrifying no one carries almond milk
and caucus-goers are extremely well
informed so at least you put a one
positive in there I could do something
similar for you know for New York I
could say observations from New York
it's crowded it smells weird driving is
impossible there are more billboards in
a city block than Iowa has in the entire
state homeless people pee on the
sidewalk people people drink almond milk
for some reason you can walk 27 miles
and never see a tree the gas stations
don't sell live bait much more
horrifying experience in my in my
opinion and you know Sally is getting a
lot of flack for this and rightly so
because it's a problem that the peep
who are tasked with reporting the news
and with keeping us informed with
telling us you know what we need to know
don't understand us that's what we get
from this they literally do not
understand us they only understand life
and culture in their urban bubble
because if you're surprised and
horrified by dirt roads and a lack of
almond milk then that's a problem that
tells me that you don't understand the
country well enough to speak to it I
don't want to get into the culture war
thing about urban versus rural although
I did inadvertently get into that and
I'll talk about that in a second when it
comes to the people I think it's a
stupid thing to get it uh are there
better people in the city or in rural
I've been I've been all around the
country I've lived on the East Coast
most of my life I've spent a lot of time
in Baltimore New York Washington Philly
you know up and down that corridor and
I've also I've lived in the country I've
lived in Kentucky I've visited probably
30 or so states in the last few years
for everywhere from North Dakota to LA
it's a California Alaska Ohio Montana
all around and people are people
everywhere you go in my experience there
are good people bad people nice people
mean people everywhere you go but in
terms of personal taste in terms of the
environment that you're in I can't see
how anyone would prefer the city over
the country I don't get that and I made
this point in response to salad
Goldenberg I made the point that out in
the country you have open spaces grass
trees wildlife privacy quiets and I just
how could you prefer crowds and concrete
to that and then I wrote that tweet I
found out this morning that apparently
the tweet sparked a backlash which which
I do sometimes I spark backlashes I
don't mean to but I do and this one did
I didn't even know it but this New York
news channel they did a story about my
tweet it's gets just watch this this is
from a provocative right wing blogger
named Matt Walsh so but maybe it was
meant to get this reaction but but
here's what he wrote yeah how can anyone
actually prefer living in a crowded City
over a more rural area with open space
green grass trees privacy and quiet I
mean do you really need to have 98
stores within walking distance is
proximity to retail really the most
important thing I don't get it
Walsh often says Atlantis things looking
for a response and he got response from
a bunch of New Yorkers including New
York ones Jillian Jorgenson who said
imagine thinking the only thing an urban
lifestyle offers is proximity to retail
I mean shaking my head at this whole
thing Darla said the opportunities to be
exposed to other cultures lifestyles
religions and creative hubs all also
within walking distance arguably part of
the problem of America right now
Robert says oddly enough people over the
age of 4 understand that not everybody
likes exactly the same stuff they do
you're here newsworthy stuff there folks
that is newsworthy material I don't like
cities you know halt the presses let
everybody know I don't like cities but I
stand by it I stand by it number one
because I have found out that apparently
people in cities are kind of whiny and
sensitive especially New Yorkers I that
is the one critique I'll make of the
people not true of all of them but I
have notices about New Yorkers that if
you don't bow down in worship New York
and talk about it's the greatest city in
the world such a wonderful city oh my
gosh New York New York it's a wonderful
if you don't do that they get very
offended they need you to tell them that
New York is great they need to hear that
from you and if you if you don't say
that
god forbid you go to New York and you
say yeah you know I was alright that's
kind of my feeling about New York I
visited it's fine there are a lot of
people there stuff there's the buildings
and there's restaurants and yeah it's
nice it's fine
it's it's ok I'm happy to leave I'm
happy to be there for a few hours or a
couple days but I'm also happy to leave
and a lot of New Yorkers can't handle
that reaction they don't like it they
need you to love it a little bit needy
in my opinion I think people out in the
country a little bit less Nene they they
they definitely don't care that's one
thing I'll say as far as the people go
if you go out into the country into
rural areas those people do not care if
you like it or if you like them yeah
they're friendly people they're nice
people but your opinion of them and of
their lifestyle they couldn't possibly
care less they're not gonna try to
convince you if you say oh I don't like
it there are too many cows it smells
like cow poop they're gonna say well
you're you're free to go see you later
but in the responses to this to what I
said the one thing that jumped out at me
is when people are talking about why
living in the city is better than living
in the country one thing that kept
coming up is convenience and how the the
city is much more convenient and I think
that's interesting because yeah I agree
in some respects now traffic is not
convenient but yeah in a city depending
on where you live you could walk outside
walk right down the street to the
convenience store you you've got
everything you want some depending on
where you live you could have everything
you want within a couple of blocks
whereas if you live out in the country
you might have to drive 20 or 30 minutes
to get to a grocery store god forbid
so that's convenient but I don't think
we want to structure our lives around
convenience GK Chesterton said that an
adventure is an inconvenience wrongly
considered meaning that yeah you could
look at it as an inconvenience or you
know if you got to drive thirty minutes
to the grocery store you can look at it
as an opportunity if you live out in the
country you look at as an opportunity to
get to see the view you look at it that
way and if you live in a
morale setting here's what I know you
walk outside your house in the morning
you're gonna hear birds chirping you're
gonna hear wind rustling the trees you
know if you have a brook on the property
you might hear water gurgling you'll
hear maybe in the faintly in the
distance you'll hear a cow mooing or a
dog barking or something and it's serene
and it's beautiful and it's to use a new
agey phrase it's very centering it helps
you center yourself
whatever that means it's human I guess
it feels like a more human experience
whereas in the city there are a lot of
other humans
so it's human in that sense but I don't
think people are meant to live in grey
and concrete all the time I feel like
this is a need you need you need trees
and air and you need that I've at least
I do all right
it is interesting though when you think
about it that so many of the people who
live in cities identify as
environmentalists yet they're nowhere
near a natural environment where as out
in the country nobody calls themselves
an environmentalist yet they live in the
environment all the time I mean I am AI
am in an environmental conservationist
I'm a beekeeper okay I am helping the
environment
I would never describe myself that way
but uh but that's what I'm doing all
right
um by the way yesterday was world bday
and none of you jerks wish me a happy
world bday even though you know them a
beekeeper and I'll tell you something I
am NOT gonna forget that how dare you
all right this is from Paul Matt wall
show at gmail.com Matt wall show at
gmail.com from Paul says mr. Walsch
you poor poor wretched creature I wonder
what could possibly have happened in
your childhood to make sure to make you
such a sniveling coward that a few girls
reject you in high school you poor baby
I know that I know that stings right but
reacting to such a blow to your fragile
little ego by spewing hatred towards
half of the species that knows how
unappealing you are will only make
matters worse for you I understand from
your stupid little bio that you found a
woman who was willing to
with you that's not what he said he used
the more vulgar vulgar phrase so why are
you still so sad and scared and angry
incidentally the phrase theocratic
fascist is an oxymoron and if you truly
believe in your deluded little noggin
that you're somehow carrying the message
of Christ I've got news for you
if this mythical figure were an actual
one he'd have you earmarked for an
eternity in Hell for being such a baby
fu please die hi Paul
thank you very much for that feedback
valuable as it is I don't have much to
add except this perhaps I am as terrible
as you say maybe that's true maybe I'm
an awful person who knows but then how
does it make you feel that you are over
in your corner stewing over me thinking
about me hating me writing to me
describing me to myself and yet I don't
know who you are or care and I never
will know who you are or care and after
this moment right here this moment this
is your moment to shine this is the
moment I'm speaking to you but after
this moment I will never think about you
ever again as long as I live and yet I'm
stuck in your head that's got a stick
doesn't it thanks Paul all right um
from Patrick says see hi Matt on the
show you were discussing your view on
capital punishment I'm curious what you
think of the argument that capital
punishment shouldn't be allowed given
that there is although small a chance of
a wrongful conviction I do believe there
are some horrendous actions one may take
that deserve death as punishment but
since our judicial system is not
flawless I'm unsure whether or not the
government should be trusted with the
power of sentencing people to death keep
up the good work
on the show I'm a big fan thanks Patrick
yeah our justice system is not you're
correct it is far from flawless and
that is a concern obviously it's a big
concern maybe the number one concern
with the death penalty to put an
innocent man to death is unspeakably
unjust and we know that it has happened
in America but I think you can get
you can be really really really really
certain that somebody is guilty or I
should say Becca you can get really
really really really close to certainty
that someone is guilty so you can be
very very close to certain you'll never
be a hundred percent certain in the
sense that I can I can't even be a
hundred percent certain that this desk
exists yeah I am very very very close to
a hundred percent certainty but I'm like
99.99999%
but there's a chance I'm dreaming
there's a chance I'm hallucinating
there's a chance I'm high on LSD I've
never done LSD but who knows I mean
maybe if you did it you'd forget that
you did it and I don't know how it works
if there's a chance that I'm in the
matrix there's a chance that that this
that this is actually a transformer you
know that'll turn into a giant wooden
robot who knows technically that's those
are all possibilities but they are so
remote so slim that you effectively
don't have to consider them and for all
intents and purposes you're certain I
think you can get close to that with a
guilty conviction these days because
you've got DNA evidence you've got even
like a video GPS I mean cops can check
on your phone see where you were you can
see you were their DNA they've got a
murder weapon now there are plenty of
times people are convicted without all
this stuff but what I'm saying is we can
theoretically get very close to near
certainty and then also people will
admit there are plenty of people on
death row who have admitted that they
did the crime now but here's my point is
it possible that someone you could have
DNA evidence video GPS a confession and
the person is still innocent yes it's
possible but it's probably about as
possible as you know the the idea that
this desk doesn't exist because I mean
I'm dreaming it's like in that same
realm which is why the standard is to
prove guilt beyond a reasonable doubt
not beyond any doubt if we have to prove
guilt beyond doubt then we
never convict anyone of anything because
you can never be technically beyond
doubt about especially about something
that someone did that you weren't there
to see and even if you were there to see
it we know that eyewitness testimony is
notoriously unreliable so it's
reasonable doubt if you're beyond
reasonable doubt then I think that's
enough to put someone in prison and if
it's enough to put someone in prison I
think it's enough to execute them as
well because it's it's certainly almost
as bad it would seem to put an innocent
man in jail for his whole life as it is
to execute him
so either way it's horrific which is why
you want to be beyond a reasonable doubt
got a few other emails I think we will
save these for tomorrow Matt Walsh show
at gmail.com Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com thanks everybody for watching
thanks for listening Godspeed today on
the Ben Shapiro show a court targets
President Trump over his accountants
records plus Trump moves to stop his
former White House Counsel from
testifying that's today on the bench
Shapiro show